ça fait un petit moment qu'on
l'attendait voici enfin le premier
smartphone avec une caméra intégrée sous
l'écran czt le qui est le premier à
sortir sa copie avec son axe aux 20 5 g
ici pas d'encoches pas de bulle pas de
points sont finies la discussion sur la
place de l'encoche la taille de
l'encoche une ou deux caméras à
l'intérieur
la question ne se pose plus tout est
intégré directement sous l'écran de
façon transparente
on ne voit plus rien mais malgré tout la
caméra est bien présente elle existe
elle est sous l'écran mais elle est
complètement invisible souvenez-vous des
constructeurs ont déjà fait des écrans
100% intégrer sans caméras visibles il y
avait effectivement aucune caméra sous
l'écran vous avez eu les systèmes de
caméras pop up qui venaient se
soulevaient asus également avec son
iphone 6 et son iphone 7 cette année je
vais vous faire pivoter la caméra
arrière pendant retrouve avec une caméra
principale qui devenait également une
caméra de cette fille bien des avantages
et les inconvénients de tous les côtés
que ce soit en termes de poids en termes
d'encombrement en termes de résistance
sont nos solutions qui sont super
intéressante mais ce qu'on attendait
réellement derrière c'est l'innovation
la caméra qui pouvait enfin se cacher
sous l'écran et ça y est enfin elle
arrive fin 2020 c'est une technologie
qu'on devrait retrouver chez d'autres
constructeurs en 2021 on va donc
surveiller de près les grandes annonces
qui vont arriver tout début 2021
d'ailleurs vous invite dès maintenant à
venir vous abonner pour tout savoir
parce que oui on va y toutes les voir on
reviendra ce qui va se passer et croyez
moi ça va être vraiment passionné
aujourd'hui 7e à cette technologie donne
forcément vont l'avoir
ils intégreront de différentes manières
et on verra laquelle il ya plus
intéressante
revenons donc aujourd'hui à nos moutons
pour parler du zte axxon 20 5 g notre
caméra cachée au centre de l'écran la
promesse d'un écran plus immersif
totalement utilisée ici c'est un écran
oled de 6,92 pouces full hd + 2490 par
1080 pixels un écran 100% dci p3 avec un
taux de rafraîchissement 90 hertz un
écran 10 bits avec 1,07 milliard de
couleurs et un ratio 20 points 5/9 cette
prouesse a été rendue possible grâce à
des nanomatériaux transparent un triple
algorithmes 2 sél fille ayant un travail
ardu ouvert différent notamment au
niveau des circuits bon ça on passe un
petit peu côté technique la one écran va
être composée de sept couches
différentes
zte réduit l'ensemble à trois couches
est ce que ça marche
oui ça n'a effectivement vous avez un
écran où vous ne voyez pas la caméra
sauf lorsque vous passez en mode
caméra en mode selphy votre écran sera
noir on a regardé les résultats des
photos dans quelques instants
quand vous regardez un film une série
est ce que le résultat à la hauteur
oui mais c'est pas parfait on devine ce
petit carré on finit par s'y habituer et
il vient vraiment fondre avec le reste
de l'écran néanmoins on voit quand même
une petite différence c'est
effectivement pas parfait c'est une
nouveauté c'est une très belle nouveauté
c'est une belle innovation qui en tout
cas ouvre la voie vous savez quand une
technologie arrive au début elle n'est
pas parfaite et reste encore des points
à améliorer et c'est le cas ici aussi
malgré tout l'expérience est super bonne
d'ailleurs dit moi vous dès maintenant
ce que vous en pensez en banc
commentaires ça vous convainc ça vous
convainc pas donnez moi votre opinion la
caméra n'est pas la seule à venir se
cacher sous l'écran vous y retrouve
également votre haut parleurs pour
passer vos appels qui est intégrée sous
l'écran puisque je vous parle de dieu
vous avez ici un haut parleur mono pour
venir regarder votre contenu multimédia
on est ici sur un smartphone milieu de
gamme
il a donc fallu faire quelques compromis
j'imagine que cette technologie au
niveau de la caméra sous l'écran coûte
très cher et eu beaucoup de recherche et
développement pour arriver à ce résultat
aujourd'hui néanmoins zte vous sort ce
smartphone à 449 euros vous avez le
premier smartphone au monde avec une
caméra intégrée sous l'écran à moins de
500 euros
et ça aussi c'est une prouesse on se
serait attendu à voir arriver ce
smartphone par le très haut de gamme a
pas loin de 1000 euros et c'est pas le
cas c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
parce que ça rend cette technologie
accessible au plus grand nombre la
caméra présente sous l'écran un capteur
de 30 2 mégapixels il ya un truc un peu
bizarre au niveau de la caméra cette
fille c'est qu'il ya un peu un effet
voile alors au delà du fait de ce film
est en dessous comme ça là pour
l'exercice est d'avoir un double menton
il ya vraiment un espèce d'effet voile
et ça c'est très bizarre et j'ai pu le
remarquer plein de fois j'ai peut
nettoyer mon écran à chaque fois c'est
la même chose donc on se regarde le
résultat des photos dans quelques
instants beaucoup axé sur les caméras de
saïfi vu comme ça en tout cas je trouve
pas ça génial et à l'arrière vous avez
pas moins de quatre caméras une caméra
principale de 64 mégapixels touvre f 1.8
un ultra grand angle de 8 mégapixels
avec un champ de vision de 120° une
caméra pour la profondeur pour le mode
portrait pour les faits évoqués de 2
mégapixels et une caméra de maquereaux
également de 2 mégapixels vous allez
lire prendre des photos à 4 cm de
l'objet vous pouvez filmer jusqu'à
quatre cas à 60 images par secondes vous
pouvez faire également des photos de
nuit et vous avez les vidéos qui est
stabilisé j'ai pris beaucoup de photos
avec la caméra de satie pour vous
montrer les résultats dans tous les cas
et vous allez le voir il ya un effet un
peu de flou on a
les sages qui est un peu poussé au
niveau du visage
on le voit d'ailleurs derrière au niveau
du fond c'est un peu ce qui va ressortir
et bon après il ya un peu de bouger
parce qu'à pas le stabilisation optique
ici globalement le rendu des photos
niveau de la caméra de celle film
satisfait pas est-ce que ça devienne la
caméra en elle même est ce que ça vient
du système de caméra sous l'écran je ne
saurais pas vous répondre mais un espèce
de voile sur le dessus et le traitement
logiciel cherche à corriger en venant
vraiment prononcé en venant lycée s'est
pas complètement dingo et c'est quand
même relativement dommage par contre le
rendu des caméras à l'arrière du
smartphone marche très bien
j'aime beaucoup les couleurs la gestion
des lumières et pas trop mauvaise là
c'est l'ultra grand angle on perd un peu
en précision mais c'est normal vous ai
fait un zoom x 2 aurait sur le capteur
principal ça marche c'est bien je vous
emmène en auvergne 1 vous voyez en même
temps les paysages à côté de chez moi ça
c'est super joli c'est le lac servières
comme ça vous voyagez vous découvrez une
fois de plus on retourne sur la caméra
de celle ci c'est un petit peu tard mais
ces deux matches je me dis que j'ai une
caméra de self est situé sous l'écran je
veux la même qualité qu'une caméra de
celle fille qui ne serait pas sous
l'écran et là on n'y est pas
complètement bon par contre le reste des
photos est quand même plutôt pas mal il
sort de bons résultats là c'est hyper
flagrant c'est relativement terne
salissent de tous les côtés il ya du
bruit derrière également ici l'afp voilà
c'est pas dingue personnellement pour
moi le résultat n'est pas là haut niveau
la caméra de ses deux filles on peut
faire de la macro si on le souhaite je
ne suis pas un grand fan de la macro sur
smartphone ici ça ne déroge pas à la
règle
on va avoir du bruit numérique un peu de
tous les côtés comme son nom l'indiqué
était axxon 20 5 g c'est un smartphone 5
g avec des antennes 5 g qui sont
disposés à 360 degrés tout autour de
votre appareil pour venir capter le
signal très facilement quelle que soit
la façon dont vous allez prendre votre
smartphone dans votre main et surtout on
a ici le snapdragon 7 165 g c'est un soc
sur smartphone qu'on connaît déjà
on a beaucoup parlé en 2020 ici rien de
bien nouveau néanmoins il marche très
bien il éprouvait donc pas de mauvaises
surprises il épaulait par soit 6 giga de
ram soit 8 gigas de ram et par 128 ou
256 go de stockage pour venir visionner
votre contenu pour naviguer pour des
jeux il ira parfaitement bien d'autant
plus vous avez du refroidissement
liquide pour une bonne dissipation de la
chaleur
on va retrouver une grosse batterie de
4220 milliampères heures et surtout ce
qui est intéressant si vous avez de la
coupe charge quatre plus de qualcomm
avec son bloc de charges de 30 watts
vous permet de le recharger deux
aux 1 100 % en moins d'une heure et
c'est un smartphone que vous allez
garder en fonction de vos usages à peu
près une journée et demie le smartphone
à de belles finitions la prise en main
est plutôt bonne il est un peu large
mais rien de bien surprenant ici il pèse
un peu moins de 200 grammes
vous n'êtes que nous l'annoncent à 198 g
vous retrouvez un capteur d'empreintes
digitales situé sous l'écran et il
tourne sur android 10 avec me favor 10.5
j'ai constaté un problème qui fait que
tout de suite c'est pas forcément un
smartphone que je vais pouvoir venir
vous recommander j'ai un problème
récurrent non j'ai pas réussi à isoler
la cause
j'ai pourtant tout de suite la dernière
mise à jour j'ai fait remonter
l'information à zte donc on verra les
solutions qui peuvent apporter
j'ai téléchargé beaucoup d'application
et j'ai changé mon fond d'écran pour
mieux voir la zone avec la caméra en
haut et ça m'a créé un problème de
reboot intempestifs mon smartphone
redémarre en permanence redémarre
redémarre redémarre et redémarre en
boucle chez obligé de retourner sur les
paramètres d'origine pour réinstaller
pour qu'ils puissent fonctionner c'est
d'ailleurs ce que j'ai fait aujourd'hui
pour vous le présenter dans cette vidéo
c'est relativement embêtant parce que si
vous retrouvez avec ce smartphone et que
vous avez le même problème
eh bien rien ne vous dit que vous n'êtes
pas pour trouver le smartphone qui
redoute en permanence avec une
difficulté pour venir isolés la cause
est ce que ça vient d'une application en
particulier
est ce que ça vient du fond d'écran qui
serait un peu plus clair sur le haut de
votre smartphone et qui crée ce problème
de reboot
aujourd'hui c'est pas forcément la
solution ce qui fait que c'est un
smartphone que je peux pas tout de suite
venir en tout cas vous conseiller c'est
malgré tout une très belle avancée on
verra comment cette technologie va
évoluer et sera intégrée au cours de
l'année 2020 tient donc une fois de plus
nous invite à venir vous abonner pour
tout savoir il pas ce que vous en pensez
comment vous le trouvez est ce que cette
technologie de caméra sous l'écran
pourrait vous tenter est ce que vous
êtes sensibles justement à cette techno
est ce que vous êtes heureux heureuse de
voir disparaître
enfin le note le poinçon l'encoche mark
et moi tout ça en bas en commentaire
quant à nous on se retrouve très vite
pour continuer à parler tech du gros
bisous beaucoup d'amour interdite